well you can take a trip to beverly
hills california to get your dream body
rocky spoke with dr dennis doss of dos
md the sponsor of this next segment to
learn more about a big body contouring
trend lipo 360.
welcome to the show dr daz welcome back
to the show i should say hi rocky thanks
for having me back thank you for joining
us now last time we talked about true
curve you are obviously a specialist in
body contouring and brazilian butt lift
but this time we're talking lipo 360
right what is that
yeah correct so i'm a board-certified
plastic surgeon in beverly hills and i
do specialize in lipo360 as well
now this is a technique of basically
liposuction 360 degrees around the body
so we can address the body from the
front sides and back
and that way i can create a beautiful
contour that looks amazing from all
angles oh that's what the ladies want
looks amazing from all angles and can
lipo360 can it be combined with other
procedures that's a frequently asked
question
so great question and yes i often
combine lipo360 with my other procedures
for example uh we i do this with tummy
tucks because the tummy tuck is going to
address the skin and the stretch marks
but the lipo 360 is going to create
contour so i can contour the sides the
back and also the front to again to
create beautiful proportions from all
directions and
of course i also combine lipo 360 with
my signature procedure which is the true
curve brazilian butt lift to create
beautiful amazing results
perfect and who is the good candidate or
the perfect candidate for lipo360 who
can do this procedure
well pretty much anybody who
wants to look better because they've got
some stubborn fat that they just can't
get rid of and they're healthy
and they are really interested in doing
it so absolutely a lot of people can do
this now what i love about your work is
that everything looks so natural so how
do you actually achieve that natural
look
great question so with the lipo 360 i
i'm addressing the entire body 360
degrees so that the body looks great
from all angles and really it's that
technique that matters i mean technique
really matters to create beautiful
results so they look great from every
angle so i you know i always analyze
every patient from every angle and then
i create a plan to address all of those
issues perfect if you're going to do it
you got to do it right
absolutely right so that's what so here
in vegas obviously it's a quick flight
or quick drive to los angeles how can
people get more information on you and
your and your services and lipo 360.
yeah i have a lot of patients that come
in from las vegas and and yeah you can
drive or fly and the best way to reach
us is to contact me on my website at
dosmd.com and we can easily set up a
virtual evaluation
and and get everything set up
electronically perfect well thank you so
much dr dos we appreciate you it's a
pleasure to be back thank you
thank you dos md for sponsoring this
segment they are located in beverly
hills california for more information
just call 855-496-4646